welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find it if they grow up to be classy
yeah or if they're just a big old piece
of trash i'm your host dave truly coming
at you on a glorious day
we're down here at aunt toddy's basement
she is so excited about our guest today
she's running around the neighborhood
with her shirt off oh baby getting in
the spirit i'm getting calls from the
post office to get her the hell out of
there my cohost is coming at you from
right next to me unamused this week
he is the founder and ceo of ru garbage
he makes the guys in the boardroom
nervous and the ladies in the bedroom go
all right whatever give it up for kj
kevin james ryan hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube as you know those
numbers are true the roof [ __ ]
cooking baby then i would be a jerk off
an [ __ ] a [ __ ] if i didn't
mention the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
check it out bonus content live streams
whole different podcasts we do on there
check it the [ __ ] out love that money
and having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the pride of the
chicago comedy scene and the new
prodigal son of astoria queens give it
up for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everybody what's up dudes b-bone sunny
day in new york we've got the creedence
pumping in the car on the way and we're
about to have a good time baby good day
feeling good the long hair ain't lying
gang because we got a little [ __ ]
star power in the building oh yeah not
the usual bums and bozos you see
dragging around the hallways here
our guest is a legendary stand-up
comedian podcaster and multi-million
dollar enterprise
he has numerous stand-up specials
you can hear him every week on the burt
cast two bears one cave he uh will be
performing at the world famous greek
theater in los angeles california may
5th let's cut the [ __ ] he's one of
the biggest one of the baddest one of
the best there is he is a capo de capo
we're talking about a true boss but the
big question about his mind today is he
garbage ladies and gentlemen give it up
for the machine mr burke crusher it is a
pleasure to be here gentlemen look at
you thank you so much holy [ __ ] thanks
for coming buddy did you get a hint of
if i'm garbage by my reach out to get on
the podcast that was the nicest thing
anybody's ever done bert texted me the
other night hey it's bert can i do your
podcast it's the first letter that we've
received
in
crayon there was barbecue sauce on it
too listen i i'm a fan i'm a fan of
podcasts in general so when you see good
podcasts i get excited and then i'm like
hey man is it cool if i do your podcast
i think i'm a better guest than i am
host
my podcast i talk over everyone all
[ __ ] time right like i'm not
someone will go uh so tell me what it
was like being on workaholics because
when i started watching and then the
guys like just telling you yeah yeah
yeah
yeah oh it's good stuff all right let's
get into it um
we know about the machine right yeah
college we know about college i want you
to take me back to the origin story give
me the nuts and bolts i'm talking about
a young kid in the hot florida sun
with a [ __ ] choco taco in his mouth
watching knight rider take us back to
that
uh so
where in florida tampa tampa tampa
tampa is different than everywhere else
miami is more more
international yeah orlando's bland yeah
it's weird
tampa's got some
stank on it it's a good time we were
just there just there i could move there
in a heartbeat tampa's got a big cuban
influence but it's still the south so it
is semi i mean i'll say my my generation
was still semi-segregated like it was
not not segregated as in people couldn't
live in different places yeah they just
didn't yeah and like there was like
hillsboro is where all the black kids
went to school plants where all the
white kids went to school chamberlain's
were chamberlain was mixed but it was
like that was that was tampa and i i
went to a private the all-black school
no no
i went to the private school in uh
downtown tampa as a kid
and but we lived in a white trash
neighborhood we lived in a real white
trash like like uh like legit white
people that's the thing about florida
white trash isn't it's always right
around the corner oh it's like there's
always a pontoon boat somewhere you can
get going and i think that's why i have
anxiety in life is that white trash is
unpredictable oh very very very molesty
there's always an uncle hanging around
it's always ice cube up someone's real
handsy
do i remember watching them hold this
kid down shoving an ice cream up his ass
and i was like [ __ ] i think i'm next
he he's got his pants off already says
thanksgiving what are you doing
i thought i was telling
jim florentine a story we were running a
half marathon and i was telling him a
story and halfway through he's like i
think you were molested
and i was like no
yeah he was like you were definitely
like he's a look on his face man that's
just tampa yeah
that's just florida bro this is
different it's a tampa handshake but
then we then we moved to
what is what was like a nicer
part of of north tampa like north
tampa's north tampa is all kind of uh
very rednecky at the time in the in the
70s and 80s and so we moved to a nicer
part of north tampa which was
uh not a gated community but like it had
an entrance you know it had like it was
called fair cloth estates and uh
and there that was a little more diverse
neighborhood there was like one black
kid chris calvin and uh that's pretty
diverse it's like a jewish kid like but
it was like the there was
yeah and then a canadian family
are you talking about the canadians just
moved in down the street a cuban family
uh but and then that's where i
became like started that's the formative
years of me becoming a grown like a boy
i was still going to private school then
i went to an all boys catholic school
and that is where i that is where i
became who i am today like i learned how
to tell a story because cuban kids were
like you sit down on a table you can
either tell a story you can't tell a
story if you can't tell a story at an
all boys catholic school get the [ __ ]
out yeah what are you bringing to the
table bro uh found out where i stood in
sports at that school uh got my first
fist fight uh all the [ __ ] that
that like turned me into who i am today
right it kind of happened there and then
i went to florida state
uh had the greatest six and a half years
of my life
and then out of florida state and i was
always i was always big fish small pond
everywhere i was always big fish small
pond and then when i went to florida
state i uh [ __ ] partied my balls off
i walked i walked onto the florida state
baseball team
that's pretty good well well too shabby
i walked off the same day
i was asked to leave in the second
inning i walked on coach mike wesley
snipes in major league
i carry you out while you're sleeping on
your cot
like south wake up to the sprinklers
baseball's an interesting
garbage angle because the coaches like
you're talking about the people that
form who you are where the coaches all
my coaches growing up my dad coached
at a certain point because he realized
the men that i was hanging around were
[ __ ]
garbage yeah like outlaws oh dude i
remember i remember when we played for
the yankees two coaches there were
brothers they had
four sons between them that were all on
our team so that like
all four of their sons were on our team
meaning they're within a year of age
differences yeah and i remember once and
uh
steak dinner at scizzler says i can hit
a ground ball past chrysler
and i was like i'm gonna put a third
base i'm 11.
and i'm like
mcqueen getting steak dinners at the
city and he goes no no and he's like
crasher toes on the grass toes on the
grass
for anyone who doesn't know baseball
that means your your heels are on the
clay toes are on the grass of the
infield toes on the grass hot box time
let's do it and this guy a grown man
[ __ ] taking full cuts
trying to hit a ball past me
and i'm just like [ __ ] get me out of
here yeah dude
one of them sundays if i can hit him in
the head jesus
bet you five bucks like knock his ass
out right now with a curveball i mean i
remember i remember there were times
when we moved to this new neighborhood i
watched these i was telling someone
about this and it didn't make sense when
i told it so i'll tell it slower we
watched these kids
catch another kid in our lake this kid
was standing on an island in our lake
running away from two boys with a bb gun
who caught him put him in his boat and
then went away with him jesus and it was
like i was on that was like rednecks
that was like real one dude had an
alligator indian kid of the jewish kid i
know there
we had one kid who ended up being a
serial killer what really her
neighborhood kid used to go into the
woods we had woods like big swamps
around there and we'd go back there and
be like
you guys i bet you i bet you i can put a
stick on my ass and we're like huh and
he's like i bet i get naked climb up the
tree and put a stick in my ass and we're
like
we were just gonna ride bikes yeah i'm
gonna try to find some frogs to blow up
yeah and then uh my sister called me one
day she's like yo
he uh killed a bunch of hookers on the
causeway whoa
shut the [ __ ] up he invited me to this
girl's house his family was watching
this girl's house
and uh he was like hey do you want to go
over to your house and cut out the
panties of their underwear though
i was like what what so you could see it
he was the first kid he was the first
kid that saw me uh that showed me
pornography first time i ever saw
pornography it was his dad's pornography
and i couldn't figure out what the [ __ ]
was because it was like you know when a
woman closes her leg but
lifts her legs up and it's just two
bulbs
and i was like what is that thing
i don't know but it's how did you get
that yeah mine doesn't look like that
so that's me in a nutshell yeah
that was a very florida backstory holy
[ __ ] french the serial killer saw dude
get struck by lightning out of publix i
mean like
i think there was a lot of anxiety in my
life i i feel like i have anxiety now
and i go i want to where it comes from
you're you're my god you're breathing by
this [ __ ] yeah
saul can't get struck by lightning out
of public so we just moved to lutz right
and so on florida avenue there's a
publix at florida and bears and uh we
it's rain thunderstorms in florida are
bad like we have bad lightning we don't
we can't have giraffes at our zoo and so
uh
yeah that's how bad our lightning is
they can they can't have any caps in our
mouth
[Laughter]
so we uh can't have giraffes at our zoo
that's the [ __ ] trashie of [ __ ]
that's not a rule that's insane i mean i
just never saw one i don't know maybe i
just never yeah i can afford it maybe i
don't know you can have all the lemurs
and tigers you want
because i'm sure your wrath ain't gonna
make it next storm
the giraffe's in the parking lot of the
publix
lowry park zoo lowry park zoo is a legit
place we used to go and so uh so we go
to this um publix and uh
and it's raining bad it's under thunder
lightning bad like to the point where my
dad we pull in and my dad's like all
right let's we're gonna [ __ ] run in
and as we're running in there's a kid
collecting shopping carts out in the
thing and my dad's like buddy that's
called natural selection
jesus
wait till the storm passes the little
guy yeah and then as soon as we walked
in
crack and
crack i mean you know
only people i want to say only people in
the south know it but because
lightning's so bad in the south and i'm
i have a real fear of lightning but when
you lightning hits in your backyard
it feels like it hit you yeah if there
is a there is a charge i have i have an
arguably true or not true story that
that that i might have gotten struck by
like one time it's it's on the fence you
don't know whether you got molested
struck by lightning i think you know
what's going on this guy's bonkers i
think i got struck by lightning one time
i was jogging and i was being molested
it was a light it was soft lightning so
it was not a really aggressive light i
don't think that's a thing except
lightning there's just a little static
electricity and it was between me and a
guy and it struck him between us and it
kind of no one got knocked down but
lightning struck him between us and me
and i was running and i was running back
in florida you'll go for a jog and then
as you turn around you'll realize a
storm's been behind you
outright and now you've got to run
through the storm and i'm running back
i'm on
clearwater beach over by el dorado we
used to have a beach house there and i
was as i'm running there's another guy
and lightning strikes in between us
scares the [ __ ] out of us and oh man my
heart was racing and i went in and my my
dad thinks all my stories are full of
[ __ ] i'm like i got struck by lightning
and he was like we're here i don't
believe this and i go no i almost got
struck by lightning he was like i don't
believe that i know a guy and my my
daughters are like sure
everything i say i got bit by a bat in
costa rica my daughters are like
[ __ ] i want you oh yeah i got bit by
a [ __ ] bat
i'm siding with your daughters on this
one yeah i got bit by a [ __ ] bad
costa rica
i think this lends into my anxiety is
like a little bit of a thing goes a long
way for me so i had this emotionally you
live it emotionally you were hit by a
bat whether you were bit by a battery
well here's the deal
that was rude to you
i have a bad bite on my leg right we're
eating dinner and i go what the [ __ ] is
this and the lady comes up she goes oh
you're a bit by a bat we had been white
water rafting and walked by a bush sick
bats hang out in bushes in costa rica i
would have freaked the [ __ ] out and i go
i got bit by bat now i think it's funny
i text doug stanhope doug stanhope's
like uh i think if you just keep
drinking it goes away that's why i
laughed right my kind of doctor i
laughed about right and then that night
my camera man this guy kendall goes uh
i'd be freaking out if i would be
freaking out i was like why and he goes
you gotta get rabies shots now yeah i'd
be on the first flight to cedar sinai
and i never got rabies shots what yeah i
ended up oh i didn't know that if you
don't so you're currently rabbit if you
don't instead of foaming out the mouth
and [ __ ] if you don't get them that
first four days you can't get them
so like i go back i'm going to africa
the next week i'm getting inoculated she
goes do you need a rabies shot and i was
like oh no no i was born by a bat in
costa rica and then she goes did you get
ribby shots and i said no and she goes
oh
that's a game changer so you'll never
get it i will
bert relax
you can you can google sumac type google
burt chrysler bat bite and you'll see it
it's a [ __ ] bat bite on my left
seriously it's a legit bat bite and then
they're the i would have freaked out
dude
my biggest fear is getting sick out of
the country that's my biggest fear the
next day i after this bad fight the next
day i wake up sweating i have a rough
night right i get on a horse on a beach
in costa rica and the guy says hey man
there's something going on with you and
i was like oh i got bit by a bat and he
was like well my horse the horse can
tell i'm like what the heck that's not
good he's like horses can read energy
really easy even just holding the reins
they can read your energy and i was like
that's [ __ ] i get bucked off the
[ __ ] horse on the beach the beat the
horse i get on the horse and we start to
go and he takes off and i'm like what
the [ __ ] and he's trying to buck me off
the whole time guy comes over grabs a
horse calms it down i'm half on the
horse half off i got out and i was like
[ __ ] this i started drinking pretty
aggressively yeah and i phoned it in the
rest of that episode for costa rica
you're a vampire dude yeah i'm telling
you so yeah might have gotten struck by
lightning probably got bit by a bat also
won the florida state regatta
and the super bowl twice yeah mvp once
yeah
what happened to the kid at publix man
did he [ __ ] him or not so he gets struck
by lightning right did he finish the
shift what's the deal everyone goes out
and the kids laying there smoldering uh
jesus uh carts carts smoldering carts
they stay scattered like cockroaches
uh-huh they're ch
and uh we're sitting there uh there was
a pe coach like i just said he did like
coaching pants on he's like a coach
looking guy
what's wrong with you man
and he's like he's like he was a coach
looking guy is that yeah you remember
those coaching pages no i know exactly
they were bike yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] good looking guy handlebar mushroom
had to be to pull those off and he's
like uh someone should we go get him and
everyone's like i leave him out there i
think he threw up on himself
leather he [ __ ] himself from here
his let his jewelry melted into his body
let him cool down a little bit i got ice
cream in the cart buddy i ain't helping
anybody
i got to get this home to the freezer
i got sherbet in here big fella
he's in the lord's hands yeah holy [ __ ]
the rain will take him you kidding me
with all this goddamn lunch meat i just
bought
four's head too [ __ ]
blazing buffalo
someone was like someone's like don't go
out there there's lightning and i i
remember thinking now as an adult going
that's the safest place to be it's not
going to hit there twice like oh yeah
it's not a shark it's not a [ __ ]
shark waiting for us in the [ __ ] it's
not like one of those snipers that like
wounds people so you come out to help
them and then get you do you remember
the dc sniper yeah i remember being
terrified of that how [ __ ] horrible
you just filled up your car with gas and
your head explodes yeah i know
anyway so
after a minute the kid gets up
looks around
he's like
shut up yeah and we're like over here
and he's like you guys and we're like
yeah
come here see that [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] straight to the bar for him he
comes in and he's like what happened
like oh you're allergic to dairy
gluten today
and then we had to sit there while the
ambulance came with someone called
ambulance and we sat there and uh was he
smoking the whole time no i you know i
don't really remember much i remember my
dad getting me away from it because like
he was like
i do remember asking him if he had
superhuman powers like i was like can
you read my mind right now bend this
spoon bend this spoon my dad's like he's
powder my dad's like that's not how you
want to go out buddy you do not want to
get struck by lighting i will tell you
that you don't get struck by lightning
killed by a dog like my dad my dad would
parent by my because he was a lawyer so
he'd show you pictures of [ __ ] that
happened to kids crime scenes and then
be like
stay away from dogs take a look at this
kid got mauled by a [ __ ] dog and
you'd be like
okay
yeah so that's my childhood
florida baby [ __ ] dude
tampa does have great it's just got
especially if you booze it's got fun
vibes strip clothes i was there within
20 minutes i'm like i could we talked
about i talked about
moving this whole operation down to
tampa i would i would just for the
[ __ ] fun of it
the problem with tampa is alligators
number one lots of alligators lots of
lightning lots of rednecks guns
everything you just told us for the last
10 minutes guns pulled on you a lot like
a lot i mean
everybody's packing down there
everyone's got a gun everyone has a
firearm and everyone is willing to pull
it out in a traffic stop and show you
that they have a gun i distinctly
remember having a gun pulled on us uh i
won't say everyone's name but
i want to so bad but some of them are
successful now and we were in
it was two two sets of cuts three three
cousins and me there were three cousins
and we used to do scavenger hunts on uh
the day before this big mass on friday
we had a big mass we'd all go to
scavenger hunt and then strip clubs and
so the scavenger hunt we stole a a bird
bath or a
lawn jockey out of someone's yard and
the guy can you say a mass yeah big mass
on because almost like a church like a
church so you do a scavenger hunt where
you steal property from individuals then
go to the strip club then go to church
and then church friday morning everyone
stay up and that's right i heard that
correct
because you had to do confession so you
can get it all out oh yeah i don't hate
it clean as a whistle baby yeah ready
for monday morning like the purge that's
hey i'm in and then after that mass we'd
go and streak the girls school
she isn't that crazy yeah i remember we
streamed the girls school and we we
didn't know the setup of the girls
school this is i mean this is like
hardcore cancel [ __ ] now we didn't know
the setup so we get totally naked we're
in a van it's like [ __ ] 20 of us
stuck in a week
we're outside
we're outside the girls school and uh
and we're like all right go and we all
take off inside of academy holy names is
the name of the school and we hit the
first floor first which is
first grade in kindergarten
we are like [ __ ] go go up and so the oh
the girls already drawing like we're
zoning on the third floor so we need to
go up three we're all out of breath when
you get up there winded winded
naked winded i mean it was like [ __ ]
you girls say anything you like
hey tammy
you're going to scavenger hunt next week
[Music]
below the scavenger hunt guy comes out
he was in the crx the crx there's a the
little one with the shoes you know
crx
blue crx
he comes out pulls up next to us we are
on
uh
[ __ ]
beta bay we're on beta bay and we're
getting going to take a left to get on
the bayshore we go to take a left he
pulls up next and he pulls out a gun and
he's
this is his car or what i just edited
his name out there
and this is our
his car and he's pulled up and he puts
the gun in the window and i'm sitting
shotgun and i just go it's a gun like
right here and i'm like [ __ ]
completely naked no no no we we've
closed this is the scavenger
hunt and so then this guy we fought this
guy
down bayshore
i mean i the last i saw this guy he was
holding onto the side of our car and we
were
punching at us and we pushed him off the
car and he rolled off on bay shore and
we kept and then that night we quit the
scavenger hunt we were terrified and we
parked in a parking lot and just in
trauma just waiting for someone to pull
a gun on us but uh jesus yeah that was
florida was florida was kind of [ __ ]
still yeah the wild west of this house i
remember one time i remember one time
driving to my buddy caiman's house and i
had a fox and this uh
mustang pulled up we were on uh 275 and
i was going fast you know like maybe 80
and this mustang flies up next to me and
gets in front of me going faster so i
pull out to get
to to pass him i'm in a fox and he just
punches it and gets in front of me again
they've been raining and he hits a
puddle any hydroplanes
spins on the interstate going probably
90 miles an hour spins hits the side
goes off the [ __ ] interstate into a
tree and because he was in front of me
he emptied the puddle and i went through
it and i didn't hydroplane and i went
mother
[ __ ] damn and i i do have anxiety i
wonder now that i'm telling you all
these stories i wonder if that's where
it comes from all this [ __ ] that
happened to me yeah i mean yeah it's
been 14 minutes and i can see where your
anxiety is you watch a guy die in a
publix [ __ ] parking lot
he lived i'm sure
there's no way that guy's alive what
about the guy in the mustang i knew i
know two other dudes got struck by
lightning also kip adam and eve baby
adamandeve.com
i've been a fan for a long
long time t-bone cut the lights and
light me a burning that's what i'm
talking about gang what's going on in
the boudoir huh need something to spice
it up a little bit everybody's looking
for a little bit of better sex yeah it's
fun now it's great it's all out there
out in the open we're sex positive let's
have fun talk to your partner gang get
over there to adam and eve and get
yourself some goodies as they say yes
adam and eve is offering 50 off just
about any i what these guys are bonkos
adam and eve are both boncos giving away
the store toys on christmas uh
coming out of the woodwork yeah just go
to adamandeve.com and select any one
item it could be adventurous new toy or
anything you desire they got it from a
to z you know try some new stuff spice
it up a little bit live a little hit me
up
[Laughter]
just enter code garbage at checkout
you'll get 50 off almost any item and
when you do you'll also get free
shipping on your entire order whatever
you offer when you enter offer code
garbage that's garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e at adam and eve.com this
is exclusive offer for specific to this
podcast so be sure to use the code
garbage at checkout
and not just get the disc discount but
also 100 free shipping code garbage
adamandeve.com do it do it can't let's
talk about athletic greens ag whoa do
you work out
what are you talking about hit me up oh
somebody's been on the ag-1 oh yeah
heavy bike gang you got to get on the
athletic greens i could tell you
personally
i started taking athletic greens yeah
one they sent me some for free uh-huh
started working out yeah tried it new
journey you're on it tried it uh-huh
loved it yeah loved it so much that when
my supply was gone i hit them up use the
promo code got a fresh bats i got a cool
bottle i get to wet our beaks on the
back end throw the powder in there throw
nice cold water in there i shake it up i
have a sip or two i go to the gym on an
empty stomach it powers me through my
workout my stomach literally feels
better after i drink it it's an
all-in-one
stock yeah 75 high quality vitamins
minerals 75 whole foods source
superfoods probiotics the whole nine
yards uh it's lifestyle friendly with uh
so if you calio uh aikido paleo vegan
dairy free gluten free got contains less
than one gram of sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals no artificial flavor it still
tastes good the good stuff i mean what
are we doing right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
it's just one scoop in a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills supplements to
look after your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d which i use every
day and five free travel packs with your
first purchase there you go all you have
to do is visit athleticgreens.com
garbage again that's athleticgreens.com
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance now back to that show yeah the
lightning was a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
like there people got struck by like
things up here jesus christ can i tell
you the funniest thing i've the hardest
i've ever laughed with my daughter
georgia my daughter isla
is terrified of bees right terrified
since she was a little kid she got stung
by a bee once and she's been terrified
she couldn't play the outfield in
softball for a certain period of time
because she just kept looking at the
floor for bees right they were all they
were everywhere too so one day one day
we go on a hike in fryman canyon aisle
is maybe
11 years old and and as we go to turn
this corner
we see people coming down going
[Music]
and we're like the [ __ ] are they doing
and we start making fun of them i was
like good good
and then isla turns corner and she goes
what's this shadow from it's a swarm of
two thousand blocks that isla walks into
it george and i are behind her we see
her walk into bees and she moved the
only way i can describe it is this is if
she got all new body parts and she was
trying them for the first time
like captain caveman
and jor and georgia and i and ida goes
bees and georgia and i fell on the
ground laughing because it was her
biggest fear and we saw her witness it
and then the whole walk down she's like
i told you bees are real they're
dangerous
and we're like that never she wasn't
stung though right no she didn't get
stung because here's the weird thing
that same thing happened to me at
lacrosse practice one time we were
standing there it was the spring me and
my boy are standing there we're goofing
around we're doing a little scrimmage
all of a sudden night or day turned to
night and we were [ __ ] surrounded by
again like 2 000 [ __ ] bees not one of
them touched us because when they're
looking for a new home they don't [ __ ]
with anybody when the clean's out really
yeah because they settled on the
baseball field a couple of gentlemen
couple of fields down really yeah we all
came out like dirt bags the whole school
to look at it while they [ __ ] torched
them
holy [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] with it but
that's your she wasn't freaked out i was
my child and i was could not stop
laughing
i could not stop laughing at her
oh my god
what was the house situation growing up
single-family home nope mom and dad uh
two sisters one sister one sister is 10
years younger than me
but just a single family home is the
house it wasn't like an apartment or
condo oh oh oh oh oh oh oh my god
you own multiple properties now i
presume and you don't know single family
yeah single family single family yeah
yeah single family no single parents i
thought you said single parent i was
like no are you just [ __ ] with us no
i just
we had plenty of cousins around
a couple of uncles hanging
no single family home yeah definitely
it was a single family home
watching you think is one of my favorite
things in the world you can see it
happening
i'm gonna have to take my [ __ ] jacket
off
i'm sweating now i'm laughing so hard ah
i can't believe this is sorry that you
answered that question he ran through
the family treats nope two sisters a dad
a mom
we were all good did you think i think
it thought it was just you racing
yourself it was five of us actually has
a five family home
[Music]
so publix was the grocery store
um we get that a lot because we're up
here so supermarkets are a big thing
publix how does publix rank
in like
where do you shop now by the way well
it's not win dixie
good or bad bad bad when dixie's the the
trash it was trashier family mart was
trashier oh that sounds familiar did you
have a food lion down there by you i
don't think so because when we were kids
there was a big remember the big scandal
with food lion oh they were like [ __ ]
taking meat from three years ago and
re-wrapping it and dishing it to people
no no 60 minutes [ __ ] got a hold of
them and didn't let go we didn't have
that we didn't have walmart we didn't
have target we have publix
and we had kmart i think but the parts
were all right publix now public schools
are high-end they're like they've
shifted if you talk to any florida kid
if you say public sub they're like
that's our wawa but
the public subs are massive they're
[ __ ] amazing they don't skimp and now
you go to a publix it's got sushi
they'll have a wine bar they're high-end
okay
now you go i'm sure
where do you go
like uh
beyond whole foods right what in l.a
yeah oh we go yeah
gelson's
gelson's is uh was where we did most of
our food shopping and now honestly we
moved to a place where
maybe i go to ralph's okay all right
ralph's respectable it's good that's
good yeah i like it do your parents did
they still live in the house that you
grew up in no
can you tell us the name of the street
that it was cobra court courts are all
right
embassy lane was the first place
we lived next to a cop a chinese
immigrant family
across the street was a bunch of chinese
people lived in that neighborhood oddly
i think one family moved in and then
moved everyone in
and then a cop lived next to a sheriff
lived next door to us and then i watched
a dude finger a girl like two houses
down we little fire three houses down
jesus christ that's how our embassy road
kind of
venezuelan family around the corner yeah
it was it was a pretty it was yeah what
kind of vacations would you guys do as a
kid where would you guys go not really
anywhere really yeah because my dad is
not that kind of guy and also tampa
you're like at the beach already you
know what i mean you got
water and stuff we went to orlando these
are the vacations i remember you've been
to disney world i assume no but i mean i
have now i have now right as a kid i
think we went but we went to orlando and
me and my sister were so amazed at the
hotel
you know
that we didn't want to leave they had a
grotto they had a uh arcade they had a
pool they had everything is just hotels
do it right down there yeah we were
literally just there yeah we didn't want
to stay and then we went to key west one
time we never left that hotel either
yeah we never my dad is not and he's not
like uh
my bad my dad the big thing about my dad
i remember i had to deal with this like
later in life and it's ironic that i'm
saying this
my dad was not a hey would you take a
picture of us kind of guy so we have no
family pictures of like i don't think
any dads in the 70s or 80s were yeah but
now nowadays with like how much i'm on
social media taking pictures of my
family and showing all my life it's
ironic cause i remember the i remember
uh i went to
i went to uh
the grand canyon with bobby kelly uh
bobby
matt frost he's an agent over at caa and
vincent nash who's a manager and i
i was really i wanted a picture of
myself in front of the grand canyon not
with everyone else by myself and i went
and it was i was shaking i had a
supposed camera and i walked up to
people and i was like
you take a picture of me
and i remember i why don't you ask one
of them why don't you ask bobby i was
too embarrassed yeah bobby what the [ __ ]
bert you want a [ __ ] picture oh you
want a [ __ ] picture you wanna fight
the hardest i've ever laughed was uh
bobby we were like because bobby and
matt and vince came around came over to
us and i was and i just got a picture of
myself i was in a jason williams jersey
and my hair was dyed
blonde no shirt on there just going real
classy just a jersey with madras shorts
you can find this picture online goddamn
and uh
jason williams jersey at the grand
canyon that's [ __ ] and i remember
there's a tough hang on we asked this
lady to take a picture of us
and she just grabbed like if this is the
grand canyon we were hearing like hey
can you take a picture of it she goes
yeah sure and she took a picture of us
without the great kid
and bobby goes how about we put the
[ __ ] grand canyon in the back
oh yeah okay and then we've turned
around four [ __ ] there to buy a
bench
station wagon i bet i got that picture
oh
my god
what was your first job
uh working for uh working for my dad at
his office okay standard first car
uh a fox
okay
have a tree fort in the backyard it's
funny how your memory is this is the
picture i'm not wearing a jason williams
jersey
so funny
but i wasn't just struck by like i swear
to god if you asked me i was wearing a
jason williams jersey in this picture
and i'm definitely not that's a good one
right oh
because it was unclothed okay uh fox a
fox there's not the car i wanted i
wanted to get a mustang i thought those
were badass i wanted one too it was my
first yeah but my dad uh what is a fox
i'm pretending like i know i don't know
what is it it's a step below the jetta
it's back in the day
a tail that went up kind of and a fox
had a tail that went down close to a
scirocco
oh no schrocco's were 16 000.
i was a hot chick car in my [ __ ] blue
dude this was a really big deal for me
yeah first car i wanted a sirocco 16 18
000
a jetta was like 14 15 000. and a fox
was like nine ten thousand dollars and
my dad's like i can get you the fox but
he got me one in the showroom so it was
like a really nice
it was a really nice car i loved that
car stick stick shift yeah nice yeah
it's good stuff
huh what's a treefort situation at the
house when you were a kid uh
any swing sets
no we had we had a tree next door that
we could climb that i would i would
climb a lot that was like a falling down
oak and so the inside was hollowed out
so it kind of looks like a pirate ship
in the middle of a good time but i was
for most of the time i was in a boat
yeah i was gonna i was in a bass a john
boat in the backyard i went down for new
year's to tampa i was in a [ __ ]
pontoon boat at noon in saint pete's
beach and like i was in with a six with
a six-pack i was in heaven yeah there's
nothing better than that i have a buddy
whose favorite memory growing up was he
had he had a nighttime job and we'd get
off he'd get in his pontoon boat and
he'd listen to hold on loosely at six in
the morning doing circles around a small
lake drinking beer yelling have fun
stepping in my jizz suckers love that
this guy parties for sure yeah tampa
florida jesus christ
hmm ever been to an air show of course
you ever seen a crash in an air show no
you'd think i would have though the way
i live my life
the way i tell stories
about what you were in yeah no yes so
there i am in an f-16 i'm coming in low
over 278 guy in a mustang in front of me
i was a stunt pilot for a day though
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
of course well it's also like you ever
done this and he's done he's had
multiple tv shows but he's like hell let
me do the craziest [ __ ] for a decade
yeah i was a stunt pilot for a day and i
did hammer head rolls to the ground i
did stalls i did flips i did everything
it was [ __ ] somebody was in there
with you oh someone in the yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i was like how do i let it rip
someone was in there and he was just it
was like very technical it wasn't as
scary as one of those two-seater drones
like two seaters i think he was behind
me those oh i would freak out man no
he was like all right
right pedal left pedal uh turn to the
right and then all you just go you just
listen to him if you just listen you're
fine and then he'd be like all right
all right pull back left pedal and then
you just do it and you pull out and it
was it was terrifying but
you're notoriously not a good flyer not
a good flyer i do not fly well and so
that was uh that was it was pretty
intense and you moved around a lot of
there
but uh yeah holy he did it we're doing
first class now right i would have so uh
yeah always yeah nice i i i
i this is where i'm at flying not to
brag but this is what are you talking
about i'm no longer airline loyal nice
that's when you know that's pretty good
because once because that's the thing
american really [ __ ] up because i was
american ride or die a ride or die no
matter what and i was buying first class
but i was only buying an american and
then i got to a place where i was like
oh i will never i'm not i can't i can't
fight coach i just can't i'm too big i
like drinking
i want to sleep and uh you're my and i
was like i was like and i and now i
realized
it doesn't it doesn't i'm never going to
use the miles i'm never using miles for
anything because anything i do is always
work if i'm taking the girls to europe
i'm doing a show in greece and that's
going to be a work trip i'm buying the
ticket anyway and so then uh i would
love to know how many miles you have oh
it's probably a stupid amount uh i pop
yeah very stupid i i'm i was i was
dragging in
i was averaging
dragging in that's a real [ __ ] that's
real cowboy [ __ ] i was dragging in about
250 000 miles a year so so executive
platinum's a hundred thousand miles a
year and i would hit that in three
months geez
but but you gotta remember i was working
for travel channel or mostly working
travel channels so i was flying back and
forth from europe back and forth from
africa
so i was playing a lot i'm that at my
height of flying i was a thing called
concierge key which you're not supposed
to talk about but i don't give a [ __ ]
heard about this and it's uh we just got
kicked out of the delta lounge yeah we
both individually got [ __ ] got booted
from the amex lounge really because our
limits weren't high enough not even a
peanut butter not even a peanut butter
nugget oh dude can i tell you what i do
now just getting money for the first
time in our lives and we're finding out
quickly that we don't really have any
money i do
i do a thing called private suite
this guy's got it all private suite you
so it's a separate entrance to the
airport so the airport this is what i've
i've heard you talk about this airports
here right and then the all the all the
business is here check in and all that
is on the left sure private suite is its
own little entity off to the the other
side of the airport so you pull in
valet like you're it's it's it looks
like you're pulling into a like to a
very private restaurant
uh they they greet you at the car they
take you to a room the room is filled
with what you tell them what you want oh
they know me so they always have tito's
they always have wine they have snacks
candies they bring in they have a menu
you can order from they bring always
bring in caviar and champagne to greet
you caviar
i'm so sorry we've had so many people on
the show you're the first person who has
an airport rider yeah that is [ __ ]
sick is it connected to an airline uh no
so so you go to the airport yeah it's
it's it's so you go to like you said
he's not these bums that we normally
have peter how [ __ ] insane is it it's
[ __ ] insane it's the coolest thing
you ever do if you want to smoke cigars
or or whatever they have an outdoor one
that's attached to an outdoor things at
the airport what are we doing gang quick
announcement on the middle class famous
tour we are going to be coming to a city
near you for a live stand-up show and
playing ayg with the audience we're
going to be in san francisco california
los angeles california la jolla
california and we'll also be in
pittsburgh buffalo detroit denver
phoenix salt lake city chicago then over
there to roseman and that's just to make
we're going to be adding some dates it's
going to be a fantastic time grab the
squad come out and see us get your
tickets it's a good time
i brought my kids my daughter was turned
uh 15 and she had her birthday and we
were i was doing atlantic city so i
brought the girls to atlantic city they
each brought two friends what a flex and
i brought all of them into the private
suite and they had a birthday cake for
isla
there and all her friends were like what
the [ __ ] is this then you get cool
that's crazy how'd that make you feel oh
like a gangster anytime any i don't have
no problem spending money to avoid
anxiety or to treat my kids i have a
hard time spending money on myself like
cars and stuff like that i'm not that
kind of guy but like
i remember one time we pulled up and the
the line for the line to get to the
airport was
i'm talking it looked like like someone
lit up a christmas tree house like like
that oh it's just a string of lines
right it was like animals
and we pulled around and we missed all
of it we pulled the others to the other
side of the airport you go in you sit
down you have a few drinks you get there
an hour and a half you can get there
five minutes before your flight and then
just they'll grab you they'll score they
take your id they check you in they
check all your luggage then they grab
you they take you through their tsa so
if there's no line it's not a line at
all you walk in they put you in a seven
series bmw or an escalade and they drive
you on the tarmac over next to the plane
and then you enter the stairs you know
when you you check your bags and then
they and then when you land they bring
them up that flight of stairs yeah yeah
you walk up those stairs and you board
the plane last it is gangster damn so if
there's a nuclear war
you're gonna be in the bunker you're one
of those people oh yeah no listen here's
the deal do you know who killed jfk
by the way i just met oliver stone
yeah
he seems like a chip hey
i love him
but he seems an intense hey google the
picture he did not enjoy pressure
yeah you two are polar opposite yeah was
very you're struck by lightning he's
talking about world war ii or something
you ever have a public sub
he auctioned the rights to my life
that's why yeah that's why i met him so
so uh but no so it's a private suite for
me is the alternative of flying private
like i love flying private is but it's
just so does not make sense financially
okay you have to be making
you have to be making you have to have
joe rogan signing bonus money and even
joe doesn't fly private all the time
like it just is so expensive to fly from
new york to la is insane so my my caveat
is
i can get private suite for a fraction
of the cost for me by myself it's six
hundred dollars
six hundred dollars for me to go private
school we don't got that
you're telling me to get tsa pre-check
yeah these bozos don't even have
pre-check yet i go through pre-check
when we go on the road go through
pre-check i got to [ __ ] wait for
these animals no caviar over there i can
tell you that you're dead weight to me
you are the [ __ ] you
[Music]
it's me foley from are you garbage you
guys stink i'm hanging with bert from
now on you gotta be a member of private
suite so that's the heart that's the
caveat you gotta pay like
hypothetically a big chunk of money for
a membership but 40 bucks what are we
talking about a couple of scratchers
what are you talking about yeah yeah
is there a payment plan situation
put one on layaway bert
i'm good for it did they take podcast
merch
we got new tour teams
coming your way thanks a middle class
famous story check it out
i promise you this i promise you this if
you're ever in l.a okay
we're gonna be there two weeks are you
really yeah and then when do you leave
if i'm there and i'm flying out i will
take you with me on private suite and
you will by the way he brings us in just
throws us out yeah
we get checked like luggage here's the
best part of it we're down on the bottom
with all the dogs and stuff
here's the best part of it is you pay
for everything in that room so
they
want you to take it with you you take it
do you take it we take it that's trashy
though that's the trash hold on they
he's got the eye mask
you guys need headphones huh who wants
headphones
this is private suite loot right here
okay this toothbrush oh that's pretty
cool though oh you just got a loose
toothbrush in your pocket that's insane
dude what the [ __ ] are we doing here
this charger so they give they give you
these chargers these lightning chargers
that charge those are pretty good the
batteries always have them in there and
when we go there we fight for them
steve fury's like i call charger and
you're like well he's talking about
private suites at the [ __ ] airport
that pulls out a loose toothbrush from
his [ __ ] jacket today's a long day
today's a long day i like brushing my
teeth i get it but that's nuts dude pop
in a cvs or drain dwayne reed they're on
every corner i keep it in my pocket you
never know
you should have a cover on it man no
it's my pocket it's so funny i was
literally gonna ask one of the questions
we do sometimes is what's in your pocket
i wish i would have done that before
that that would have been insane a
thousand dollars a loose toothbrush
headsets i got 35 grand and two xanax
two bitcoins some loose drugs and
toothbrush 400 worth of fish eggs
still good i gotta eat them by noon i
just eat them i love that you take
everything i just oh you take everything
you we empty that [ __ ] place
i mean it they have nothing left in that
room when we leave and especially during
pandemic they were like they had to
trash it because someone is just there
it's the justification so i mean we're
talking and they know what you like so
now like they leave extra chocolate
covered almonds
extra skittles
extra they have wine
not that many beers they have these
little
immunity shots we [ __ ] take
everything man love it i take the caviar
spoons too
so i can do bumps later
use them for my screen
makes me feel like a giant
by the way it's how i eat my tricks
eating ice cream with a sample spoon is
the [ __ ] greatest dude so only way
what kind of animal eating with a
regular [ __ ] tablespoon all right
sample spoons samples a ladle if i could
oh like a lot of milk with my cocoa
puffs
man you are something else jesus christ
have you ever been to small claims court
i'm not okay will you sit at the counter
at a diner
i will
you don't have to look but in your
pocket right now are there any bills
with tape on them no
you can do that right away have you ever
owned a lizard snake or a bird
all of them
have you ever
stuffed somebody in a locker or been
stuffed in a locker yourself
actually done it i've been stuffed in
locker yes
late bloomer huh
a couple of weeks ago
that's agora after he has a couple of
drinks it really
gets real handsy
airport believe it or not
[Laughter]
uh
hmm were you ever big into auto trader
magazine nope
ever ruined a family vacation or
gathering
i mean
probably this week if i had to get a
couple times a couple
a cup of a
fair amount of times like straight like
everyone left too drunk or you said
something
uh a number of times
hey you showed us a toothbrush all right
give the guys yeah what do you want um
do you cut your burger in half when you
eat it
general really
will you take the steak knife from a
nice steakhouse no
when was the last time you stole a pint
glass from a bar
probably pretty reasonable yeah i could
just yeah well yeah we just because i
make irish exits irish goodbyes so well
you sneak the beer out so you can have i
don't know why can i just walk it yeah
you kind of got that cache now
i got struck by lightning i don't know
what's going on
[Laughter]
in the last 365 days have you [ __ ] in
your pants oh god yeah
are you [ __ ] serious
private lounge over here hey boys i
shouldn't give you all the pants you
need
um
all right anyone in your family play
semi-pro football
no okay
you ever wore pants that zip into shorts
yeah
that's a very florida yeah you gotta be
ready to party but they only zip once
and then you never go back to this yeah
you're like well it looks like i have
shorts now i lost that leg yeah that's
what nobody thinks about you gotta walk
around with half a set of pants in your
pockets
where you gonna put your
toothbrush magazines in the bathroom yes
okay um have you ever had a quail egg
yes yes yes yes
yeah i love them i just had [ __ ]
about 15 the other day 15. yeah i had a
full [ __ ] jar a big omelet
yeah i've had a large amount of quail
eggs i love i actually love quail eggs a
fifteen quarters it wasn't that time i
needed to come in the jar we got a jar
quail eggs i ate all of them i ate them
in the [ __ ] car ride over i couldn't
stop eating them i love quail eggs wait
they were hard-boiled yeah
hard-boiled i've had i've had i've had
every type of quail
now that you say that i've i've really
enjoyed i would say duck eggs i love
eggs i love eggs big eggs i like eggs
too i like eggs what do you do if you
crack an egg and there's like the double
yolk oh jack off yeah that's good right
i jack off
i take time i take pictures of it i take
pictures of it i post it on instagram i
send it to rogan look what my [ __ ]
look at my chickens are doing yeah yeah
it's a good time root beer birch beer
root beer
you didn't you could have said anything
after that
do you have a specific brand that you
like no a w barks oh a w is my what we
have on the bus i love a w uh-huh uh but
i love going and finding sm like of
i'll tell you right now in a parallel
universe i am brewing root beer in
northern washington
with a beautiful blonde swedish wife six
kids and a shitload of quail eggs and
[ __ ] and a lot of saint bernards oh
that's a good time uh you got the tour
bus now is there is there an essential
item for the tour bus that really ups
the quality of life for you
uh
yeah a water pick
i couldn't get into it i tried it i
couldn't get into it i like it i water
picked probably twice a day
i love water tried i bought one
everybody was raving i got one i just
didn't stick you floss every day i flush
every day you do yeah you do old school
floss or the picks picks right the
glides
and let me tell you something they're
fantastic if i find a pic i know it's
mine i'll use it again wow do you smell
them always oh you gotta smell them
fingers fingers on this on the floss run
them down and then to the next i told
him that his mind was blown you gotta
smile i've been doing it ever since it's
some of the ripest [ __ ] you've ever had
in your life dude i have a hole in one
of my molars that's why i'm water
picking so much lately and i in the
morning i will i will water pick that
hole and the smell that comes out is so
aggressive yeah what's what's
going on in there it's right it's like
bacteria i'll show it to you take a look
where oh right there yeah
and uh it's good-looking tongue though
thank you looks like he was chewing
firecrackers
oh i have oh i should tell you this i
got hit in the mouth of the baseball bat
when i was 11. and i lost 26 teeth so
all the time all the teeth you see who
has that many teeth
you have 32.
32.
well i'm an [ __ ] it's like the 7 10
split jesus christ but you've never
crowded your teeth no i've never counted
my teeth
that would have been a great question
how many teeth do you think you think
you have
115
i don't know two 220
whatever it takes you know what i mean
what movie is that from what to do
michael keaton what are you working on
some electrical work yeah what are you
doing do you want to do 20 whatever it
takes yeah once you come out in here ron
i'm sure you're doing a little my time
off people can i grab one shut up
that's [ __ ] great yeah drinking beers
with the machine during the day let's
[ __ ] go yeah this is it this is what
we play for
uh have you ever had one of those magic
wallets
where you can go like this yeah of
course of course i've been saving that
for a year
of course i did
if you're getting a baked potato what
are the toppings that you'd prefer on it
you're not gonna like that he's gonna
paint his masterpiece just butter i'm
all right with that classic right up in
the middle put one full stick of butter
on a baked potato
i [ __ ] love butter it's awesome big
one from a statement
i use it like icing i'm telling you
something i use it on can i tell you i
dated a chick who put it on a pop-tart
one time and a game changer someone was
just talking about that i'll give you
something
get a honey bun
put in the microwave with a butter on
top for like look at him
his eyes just rolled back in his head
for like 12 seconds
enter nirvana unbelievable my daughter
puts them on oreos
butter on
oreos she put man she has a butter
problem i love dude
she just gave up veganism so isla my
youngest was like one day came down i'm
going vegan and we're like that's stupid
sick i'm going vegan i have headaches i
don't i think it'll get rid of them and
so she was vegan for like six months
seven months maybe
since april april right
the other night she comes down and she
goes i'm done
let's get a pizza i said what she goes
pizza sausage and onion and then we're
like
okay and then the next day she goes
steak i need a steak back on the horse
and then we went to in and out last
night for dinner i mean she is [ __ ]
back and she walks down that burger
yeah [ __ ] punching cows when she
walks by them
[ __ ] don't look at me
uh pop-tarts are toaster strudel
pop-tarts oh wait toast them strudels
that's not what they're called
i thought they were called those for the
record photos
droodles are those toasted strudels
just so everybody toast them strudels
no it's toaster strudel and by the way
bert it is april okay i just wanted to
let you know that it's march oh yeah oh
oh it was about a year ago
wait is it toasted strudel no toast
toaster you're making a steak pillsbury
[Music]
uh toast them strudels that's the
mandalorian effect you're talking about
mandela effect mandalorian effect
i'm surrounded by boses birds rubbing
off on me it's toasty
you got a bad case of the cruisers it's
called toaster strudels toaster strudels
pillsbury toast all this years i thought
it was toasted that's going viral
which they were awesome when we were
kids but i don't know about now now the
pop-tart has really
really come into itself yeah they really
know what they're doing i'll tell you
what hot or cold i i'll tell you what
when especially when someone takes
something that's industrial corporate
and then makes it thrown have you had
homemade pop-tarts no how do you do that
i get them like a lot of people will
bake stuff for our show like the baker
stuff
we had a woman not trying to throw
anyone under the bus we had a woman one
time because i like i like uncrustables
yeah she made me an uncrustable donut
her homemade uncrustable donut wow that
was so good wow tim dillon woke up at
six in the morning and got an uber to
her place
and bought some for himself before we
left that morning they were that [ __ ]
shout out to timmy yeah timmy d knows
what he's doing
but i've had homemade pop tarts and they
are wow wow
if there was just a little more filling
in them yeah they've got to be totally
great they got to be like double stuffed
so homemade pop-tarts probably are
probably like this big this this but
they're this thing
and they [ __ ] come in your mouth
that's what i'm talking about will you
do a fig newton a hundred percent
a sleeve of figment yes you can't just i
don't do one cookie i'm not a one cookie
guy i'm a i'm a i'm not really one of
anything
i'm gonna suck down a regrettable amount
of cookies
favorite cookie one cookie what is it
oreos
i have a problem with the orange
standard straight up regular double
stuffed double stuffed okay you ever put
them in milk and crunch them up you need
to make cereal i'm sorry i apologize
yeah i don't mean to insult a gentleman
take i'll take nutter butters and leave
them on the counter for an evening so
they get stale and they're soft and with
when it comes to oreos i
soak them i take the fork shove it in
the icing and then i stick it in the
[ __ ] thing until it's [ __ ] good
and then pulled out still attached to
the fork and to the mouth
god get the icing's hard and the
cookie's soft yeah i love it
yeah it's something else this is a big
one okay this might determine
a lot okay all right i'm gonna give you
two choices
hellman's mayonnaise or miracle whip oh
hellman's without a [ __ ] i almost had
you escorted from the premises
i
made the big mistake in college of
getting miracle whip thinking it was
mayonnaise
it ain't and it stinks and i i cause i i
like mayonnaise sardines and saltine
crackers whoa mayonnaise salty sardines
and saltines crackers how are things in
the 20s
jesus christ isn't that what they ate in
the burbs
in that movie the weird family
that's civil war [ __ ] right there jesus
that's like finland's [ __ ] who does that
i loved it especially served on the
titanic it's so [ __ ] good this guy's
old-school saltine a dab of mayonnaise
with the with the sardine and uh and i
and i picked up
uh miracle whip and i was trying to
explain to a girl how good it was and i
used miracle whip instead and all of a
sudden i put in my mouth i was like this
isn't one
get it out i got the wrong thing in my
mouth this is peanut butter
miracle whip stinks uh you can only
choose one the cool ranch dorito or the
original nacho cheese original nacho
cheese of course [ __ ] gentlemen bagel
bites or pizza rolls
pizza rolls whoa
uh at the chrysler household now single
family no who all lives there please
tell them no it's me my daughter my wife
got two dogs
had a parakeet and all what the [ __ ]
happened to him is the butter on the
counter is it in the fridge butter's on
the counter whoa is it salted or
unsalted unsalted is that a you thing or
your wife thing that's on my wife's
thing yeah we uh eggs on the counter
butter on the counter you can't do eggs
on the counter oh yeah hold on are you
do you have chickens yourself though we
had chickens they're all dead now but we
were eggs on the counter butter on there
oh yeah
feathers on the eggs like it was and we
got the best eggs now they're all dead
eggs in the eggs in the fridge and he's
gotta go butters still on the counter
yeah okay butter's still on the couch
grow up butter on the counter oh no yeah
oh no butter in the fridge peanut butter
in the fridge peanut butter in the
fridge hot sauce in the fridge man was
raised by wolves yeah
everything in the fridge everything in
the fridge ketchup ketchup in the fridge
ketchup shrimp yes yeah yeah syrup
in the fridge cold syrup on an eggo in
the morning not my wife my wife's
syrup in the count are we talking like
aunt jemima or like proper maple syrup
when i was a kid we didn't get proper
meatballs
at publix yeah
when the lightning wasn't there
when you weren't [ __ ] storm jason
wonderbread white
or strowman wheat wonderbread white yeah
whoa
that's a curveball i like it it just
made me mad that question any relatives
uh aunts uncles that you don't call by
their real name like an aunt tooty an
uncle cookie a jojo and quinny uncle
pooch whoa
uncle bones you got pooch and bones
mama jim
mama jim mama jim
uh hobby yeah
what are you in leonard skynyrd mama jim
all of them all sound like roadies by
the way it's like oh yeah yeah
yeah
mama jim on the buckets
yeah mama jim raises solo mama jim
playing the caviar spoons y'all yeah
yeah um yeah a lot of nicknames or big
we're a big nickname family you got a
nickname in the family we've got a
million
a fetus from the family no no oh foreign
from the family i'm birdie boy to
everyone everyone called me boy boy uh
be bopper uh my daughters call me fetus
bertrand mcfuzz
uh fetus bertie gaga they never they
never call me daddy their dad
i
dad's
one time i remember one time i i messed
up and what i wanted to say was dad
please but i said daddy please and my
[ __ ] sisters lost their [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're like did you just call him daddy
yeah you drop a daddy at a certain age
it's like your dick falling out of your
pants or seeing your mom's [ __ ] it's
bad
god
oh
holy [ __ ] how do you feel about the
rotisserie chicken [ __ ] come on yeah
gang baby
i will not buy
whole chickens and rotisserie them
myself because they're the same price
you can yeah for the same price it's
like a nickel you get a whole chicken
you get a whole chicken sitting in its
juices for hours it's it's the greatest
oh you make chicken salad out of those
how do you eat it you just [ __ ] go
just go i i i quarter it immediately i
go
take i take poultry scissors
real quick but for let's let's be very
real if we have a rotisserie chicken i
take the top off and i pull off one thin
leg and i eat the fine leg very quickly
very quickly with some el yucateca hot
sauce mixed with ranch okay then then i
what what color you could techa uh the
xxx the hottest one that makes you [ __ ]
blood
where are you mixing it are you having a
ramen plate
on a plate okay ranch el yucateca mix
them and i will do
uh one thigh one leg then i'll cut up
i'll
take scissors cut the breasts up and i
cut the breasts in jamaican chunks you
know where they just sliced yes they
just cut jamaicans will just cook
yeah yeah yeah i do that and i will eat
a half a chicken standing over it when
we get it back from the grocery store
i'm at the counter you're going that's
like a bag of chips at the counter i i
love rotisserie chicken like you can't
bring if you bring one home you need to
bring two home knowing that i'm gonna
take that first one down love it love it
i assume you're a big eat the groceries
when they get back on a saturday it's
nice oh we talk about fresh fresh meat a
fresh sandwich a french fresh like
turkey and cheese or whatever on a nice
roll i'm gonna eat the groceries in the
store gunny guy too or do you walk out
with like an empty wrapper like hey i
had this loaf of bread or whatever yeah
that's so tragic hey you're all out of
grapes
supply chain issues i guess huh
the first time i ate fruit i ate these
cheeses for open
i ate fruit and then i brought it up and
i'd eaten half of it like cherries
and cherries all pits and [ __ ] and then
the
woman's like
i don't know how many of you you're
gonna have to get on the scale sir you
ate and i was like
station she goes but you just ate a
bunch but you haven't paid for them
she was eating cherries and just
spitting them in the thing and she was
like how many did you eat that's like a
lot
and then
i don't know
but we used to do that with bread we
might they bring la brea breaker we
bring over bread and i get my daughters
and we'd rip the top i'd rip it in half
and they just tick their arms and the
bread with a stick of butter just going
[ __ ] buttered as bread butter to
bread in the back they're back in it
the galsons the gelsen's
right before the pandemic gel since
across the street from my old house
it opened a wine bar in it
and so you could go in i would go i love
this more than anything walking in
around sunset going to the wine bar
having a glass of wine then doing a
little bit of grocery shopping then
coming back having another glass of wine
and then doing a little grocery shopping
the most part coming back having another
glass of wine and then buying a bottle
of wine from them and going home and
being like i got groceries [ __ ]
hammered it was the [ __ ] great i ate
half of them but still dude some cherry
pits in there i hate to pay
i mean at one point i would i had
stepped it up and i would i would take a
vape pen and all of a sudden i'm getting
[ __ ] yeah you're partying club
hammered like club hammered at a grocery
store coming back with the weirdest [ __ ]
i'm like hey we're making matzo ball
soup tonight she's like [ __ ] one's
monkey balls it's august
[Laughter]
i would get some weird purchases back
then god
this guy's [ __ ] out of his mind
who um
will you put gum under the table oh yeah
well you eat gum from under the table
it's like a goat no i look over he's
chewing the can
go get off the couch come under the
tables should be understood the one the
one of the worst ones and this is one
saguero makes fun of me for the most was
leanne and i when we first moved in
together
uh we we lived in this apartment
downstairs then we moved to the big
apartment upstairs that night
segura and christina came over for
dinner in our new apartment
and we had moved our
we moved our uh dining room our
coffee table upstairs and as we were
moving upstairs we lifted it and we
flipped it upside down to carry it
and underneath i had been taping my
toenails taping them i would cut my
toenails and then instead of throwing
them away i'd grab tape and i tape them
and then i'd tape them onto the thing
thinking one day
so like
my goal was one day we'll see this and
we'll laugh right
and then i would got to be there the day
leanne saw it and i got to see the look
on her face and i could not stop
laughing at the look on her face of like
oh i forgot i did that for both of us so
that we could both see it and she told
it to tom that night and he looked at me
like i was a [ __ ] wild animal yeah
you're kind of looking at you like that
you're taping your toenails to the
bottom of the table and i was like yeah
taking the time to tape the toenails one
thing to like flick it behind the couch
or oh i do that with uh with with um uh
q-tips i put them on the door jambs and
no one can reach them so i and no one in
my house can reach the door jams
where's that paint where's the payoff on
that [ __ ] they're just all every door
jam has a [ __ ] set of q-tips 30 years
from now we're gonna have a real big
laugh
and i'm dead and gone and you guys go to
move those new owners are gonna laugh uh
that's great where do you all right if
you're in your car you know and you pick
your nose where's that going in my mouth
whoa
ladies and gentlemen we interrupt this
broadcast
holy [ __ ] did you just admit to being a
booger reader eater
if i get a good one i get excited oh
we're gonna have to cut this
yeah don't be don't be giving out stuff
that you're gonna make us cut later on
leanna [ __ ] gets so mad at me she'll
be like did you just eat a [ __ ]
booger
what's the difference between this and
that
oh i mean have you ever snorted and you
get a chunk of booger in your mouth yeah
yeah it's the same [ __ ] thing it's
called society yeah right
there's rules dude
he's got his pants on them this kid's
bonkers i'm jonathan living siegel
that i've read
holy [ __ ] in the mouth
wow
and i don't give a [ __ ]
i wipe from the front and i eat boogers
i don't give a [ __ ] i wiped from the
front for a long time you switched yeah
wait what do you mean from the front go
in go in between front yeah i do that i
think
well you'd know yeah i don't know i
never got to wipe your ass
i think i go in from the front yeah i go
from the front yeah go catch her and
when i when i go catch him dude throw
the signs when i and when i i've said it
on stage at times where i i've talked
about wiping my ass
and oh cause i'm because i'm right now
i'm at the
right now i'm at the cusp weight 255 of
whether or not you're too fat to wipe
your ass i've i'm crossing that bridge
now yeah and so when you get there way
bigger than 255. i don't know why i
didn't mean that
i wasn't trying to misrepresent myself i
guess it's a personal weight for each
person i was waiting for trainers today
i'm 403. i admit that i meant it's
starting to become
a problem patreon you just dropped 403.
it's starting to become an issue uh
backstage you've gained 13 pounds in the
weight loss challenge good to know
the vegas odds were 20 so i'm doing okay
hey i made out like a bandit regardless
but i found a solution for it a reacher
no what hiring somebody
is that what this guy does
i picked him up at the sky lounge you
get a stick i guess big pun had a stick
that he'd wipe his ass with i picture
one of those things that like throw the
tennis ball for the dog that would be
really good yeah something like that but
with the claw
my girlfriend's going to be really upset
oh i love this um so we have uh you know
a detachable shower hose
so i've created what i call the american
bidet
which is i do my business
i do my business i flush it so no one
sees that there is no toilet paper in
there and i get in the shower and i
squat down and i put it on the massage
and
i blast it out well you know hello tushy
that's a great option yeah installs in
under eight minutes don't don't eat any
of that
[ __ ] guy
there better be one in that bag
yeah even every head in my apartment
that would stall one right now that's
what you're dropping you've got to pay
to play around here chrysler that he
looks mattresses out there too bird what
the [ __ ]
toby give me my athletic greens right
now yeah i agree give me my ag-1
these mugsy jeans are comfortable
i'm stuffing blue shoes down my mouth
that's coinbase.com folks
i think i could use some therapy
betterhelp.com promo code garbage that
one i'll get behind
folks are you sitting in the shower
are you a fan piece of [ __ ]
the girl was the first person to turn me
onto bidets i would like i've used them
in europe they're fantastic i have a
backless toilet so i can't get one
a tank the city it's a tank
oh okay yeah yeah the those the [ __ ]
bidet is a game i know i am yeah i get
it going so hard it breaks the the
o-ring so i like to put your butt i like
it to go in a little bit yeah start
things i like it nice and clean back
there as fat as i am i do and i even
sometimes if i don't have time to take a
shower in my home toilet i want that on
record in my home toilet i will poop i
will flush
and then as i go in to wipe my butt i'll
let the toilet paper hit a little bit of
water and then i'll do it like that
really yeah get a little wet wash on
there that brings up a question if
you're in a public restroom right i love
it i'm already excited and you gotta
poop
it's an away game you know not ideal but
you got to do it how are you cleaning
that toilet seat what's your procedure
i say you're not doing anything you're
bare-backing it he's eating boogers
so what are you talking about so uh
for the most part i i was i was a big uh
toilet seat cover guy like the like the
can't get the spread though well they
don't go that you got to rip the front
and then kind of you got its piece work
i had it i had an incident with one of
them one time where i long flight i take
a [ __ ] the airport long flight get home
wake up the next morning naked and my
wife's like did you take a [ __ ] at the
airport yesterday i was like there's a
flight attendant in there
that paper toilet seat cover was still
there in your in your underwear
i don't wear underwear so i had taken a
[ __ ] on it i'd sat for so long it became
one with me that's my bike i put my
pants on over it i sat on it for a
five-hour [ __ ] flight i then i then
went to sleep in it and then got up and
it was still there and liam was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like a craft single so
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but now it's
kind of like now i'm kind of like
i don't know it's rough i don't think
you need to do anything i'll look for
piss but if it's dry like yeah you got
to make sure it's dry now here's a
question for you if you sit down on a
toilet seat and it's warm does it get
does it just happened to me yesterday in
the bathroom here and i'm pretty sure it
was toby which bothered me as i was
pregnant yeah if you know the person i
was just mined out at mind over matters
what one did he choose and i thought i
chose right but i sat down it was warm
and i'm like oh i picked the wrong one
yeah but i was already in there
he'll dump he'll take toilet paper
put it in the water wipe the seat
you're eating boogers dude hold on
you got a loose toothbrush in your
pocket you're eating boogers man
no no no no that's what you're doing is
way worse
what you're doing is way [ __ ] worse
it's way worse dude it's way worse
builds up the immune system dude he's
doing that mid pandemic he's just raw
dogging it into a toilet were you raised
by [ __ ] poppers
were your were your were your parents
train jumpers
[Laughter]
going down to town pooping in other
people's bedrooms no no this is how we
do it this is how we do it
insane
good god oh god this is we have a
preferred benedict
salmon florentine crab
uh what do you like well you know what's
are you an egg benedict guy i'm i'm a
big i'm a big egg benedict guy but i end
up just eating the egg
uh i don't oh i'll tell you what if i
have an egg benedict that i could pick
catfish eggs benedict whoa i had it the
other day you're not eating the english
muffin i don't touch a muffin
why not uh i don't know you not like
them no no i don't like them either i do
it's just that i got to be wait hold on
hold on you don't like english muffins i
have a weird i have weird punitive
things in my diet that you know some
crannies that i don't [ __ ] with so like
um
so like if i eat a hot dog i will take
half of the bun off and then because i
love hot dogs but i feel really guilty
with that much bun so i'll take half the
bun out and just use half of a bun to
eat a hot i get that and so with eggs
benedicts i love eggs benedict but i
feel really guilty eating the muffins
the muffins and i know that the part i
really likes the egg and the meat and so
i'll just get eggs benedict sometimes
i'll just get to eat the egg part i love
eggs you are such a rare form of
gluttony and discipline yeah we need
like it's a bizarre it's i'm a bizarre
like i i was explaining to someone the
other day i
i
i'm more effective in life if i'm
hungover i'm more i get more done
because i wake up with a fire under my
ass going working going you [ __ ] up
you partied last night you deserved this
get the [ __ ] out of bed let's get on the
treadmill let's work out let's get [ __ ]
done
uh and if i if i haven't drank
i wake up and i'm like oh i feel pretty
good i think i'm gonna have breakfast
this morning and then i'll make
breakfast and then i'll be like i'm
gonna hang go get a coffee or whatever
yeah so i [ __ ] done if i don't don't
have the motivation yeah if i drink i
have motivation because i wake up and i
go one day one piece of [ __ ] one day
you're gonna wake up with a stroke one
day you're gonna be dead you need to get
the [ __ ] out of bed this you need to get
that poison out of your body time to
work out get on the treadmill get in the
sauna get in the polar plunge let's get
[ __ ] working and get on the phone add
a couple podcasts get on go to new york
get there early like yeah that's how my
brain works
it's working don't [ __ ] do it you
know it ain't broke don't fix it
something else my friend i'm a really
i'm a i i'm a like uh what's it uh like
a shark because i can't stop moving yeah
i start moving i start getting depressed
and i start getting in my head and then
all of a sudden i [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's like i don't i just don't need it
yeah yeah i get it i got to keep it
cooking
that's why i like going out when i go on
tour i go for three weeks straight
and i just don't come home because if i
come home it's just i'm it's like i'm
slowing down
so i just go out and then you work every
single day you work and like
they just started putting because i was
doing it so bad they just started
putting
literally a day in my calendar where
they're like day off and then i'm forced
to take the day off i don't
i can't
i'm [ __ ] i'm supposed to have a day
off next monday and i [ __ ]
already booked schultz's podcast i'm
like [ __ ] that that's not working yeah i
go [ __ ] that's like yeah you're like
oh this doesn't work no is this what i
mean
are you being serious like
we're laughing and drinking beers in
this light outside this is far from
where someone's telling me that this is
a [ __ ] job yeah no i mean i know we
make money doing it but don't worry i
was winning i was waiting tables for ten
hours two years ago let me tell you
something i'm not i'm not doing double
shifts on that [ __ ] yeah like i'm doing
double shifts on the stuff i love doing
of course yeah enough for sure for sure
man you are the machine
um
preferred
casual dining
establishment
not fast food not fast food olive garden
applebee's friday
uh
what
preferred
it's an italian restaurant
olive garden no i can't i can't [ __ ]
cabreras no no no no no
oh no i can't do any of those types like
if you had to choose no you got to go
you got to go to a tjf fridays of
chili's
a ruby tuesdays um
a bonefish grill oh i like bonefish a
lot yeah all right i like i like one of
those like a carabas
okay i don't i can't do chilies
everything in chili seems pretty
processed to me yeah uh
i i can't do cheesecake factory because
everything's really yeah we just went
for the first time wherever the [ __ ] we
were on uh syracuse hiroku's my mind was
blown oh it's but if you look like i was
in a casino if you look at the calories
they're through the roof
you're not a friday's guy
no i mean i am if i'm on the road in
like richmond and then and that's the
only place you have necessity yeah i
remember going to uh
i think
chili's the first time when i first saw
fajitas i was telling my dad this you
can hear them coming and that was the
first time i was looking around 10 years
old and they came around the corner and
i went i like was like yeah and my dad
just goes you can [ __ ] forget about
it yeah that's a [ __ ] nightmare with
you i'm not getting it you're going to
get burned [ __ ] that we're not getting
that
but yeah i remember i remember seeing
this for this the first time i was like
that's that's the way i want to live
yeah my family never had the confidence
to order fajitas they were like a very
don't look at me type table you know
that [ __ ] wasn't coming to the phone
really but i know exactly what you're
talking about i had that moment too like
god damn what the [ __ ] those guys are
partying over there yeah shit's still
cooking oh walking it through the
restaurant
god i love fajitas
[Laughter]
like that's my go-to order if i'm going
to eat it mexican food it's fajitas yeah
it's a good time
what's the coffee pot situation at the
house uh
so it's it's mixed
we have a
we have a
i think it's called a bremel it's a
really nice coffee break they're really
good we got i have that juicer the bread
is that it you put all the beans in it
first and then you put the water in it
and then you tell them how many how much
you make and it makes it for you pretty
good my my wife does that every morning
however i have i've started something
called a happiness journal and so
because because i saw rob dyrdek talking
about quantifying his happiness i
watched that and i was [ __ ] sorry i
can tell you how many bad days i had in
the past five years i'm like wow that
was crazy it was like six or something
like that but what i started doing was
going i know the things that make me
unhappy but i still do them and i was
like i can like hot sauce i know that
hot sauce makes me unhappy i know it
does and i still do it
and i was like i wonder if i could just
really kind of highlight the things that
make me happy and then because they're
things that make you happy that after
you do them you're like i i'm always
feeling good after i work out so one
morning i woke up and i did not want to
get out of bed and i went hold on i
wrote down on my happiness journal that
working out
and hanging out with my daughters or two
things i can identify that made me happy
but i still want to stay in bed and i
went hold on
you know these are things you are
identified that make you happy so get
out of bed and go get coffee for the
girls so i got both the girls their
orders and leanne order in my order and
then i came home and i made breakfast
for georgia and we hung out and then i
was like now and go back to bed and then
george was like you're gonna work out
and i was like i know that it makes me
happy so i went and i worked out and
then all of a sudden i had the [ __ ]
greatest day and i was like ah so that's
what i've been doing is trying because
of rob deardog trying to identify the
things that make me happy and focus on
them so like today i said um i know
alcohol makes me happy but i also know
that if i drink alcohol at barstool i
will then be unhappy yeah
podcast was my swing books i know up i'd
drink big day so i was like i was like
if i can get to here
and know that i and not be drunk then i
know i'll be happy sure so i got here
and then you were like do you want a
beer and i went i do because i know i'm
happy great i just got it all figured
the [ __ ] out
just highlight the things that make you
happy write them down just write them
down on a [ __ ] piece of paper and
then even things like when you go like
you know you know stretching in the
morning make some happy then just add it
into your life and then you can find
more happiness i guess it's pretty
simple to do yeah on paper i mean you
know it's easy to yeah but it's tough
when you're faced with it like to get
out to actually get out of bed like you
said most people don't [ __ ] i'll just
stay in bed
man mr bird christian ladies and
gentlemen
how about him this has been a [ __ ]
wild ride it's a [ __ ] heater this has
been this has been revealing i like it
see this is we could do it honestly 14
more episodes
i'm gonna i'm an analogy no now
nominally an anomaly i'm an algorithm
i'm an algorithm
[Laughter]
i'm more of a metaphor to be honest
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen the world
famous greek theater in los angeles
california may 5th yup so you're at the
king's theater while you're here you're
torn all over the place yup you are the
machine i'm in brooklyn i've never
really been to brooklyn when i lived
here i i have been a bro i go to
brooklyn like once every three months
yeah yeah i was thinking about going to
peter luger's tonight
that's a tim dillon move isn't it
nothing wrong with it
luger's is good all right well okay yeah
yeah lucas is great okay any more
questions well yes we have it well he
just brought up luger's right yeah we're
a big steak we're a big steakhouse
company over here big steakhouse fam
say you go to lugers you the security
whoever
what how what give me the give me the
rundown real quick it's bert's dinner
it's burst dinner hey you're going it's
gonna be you jay him oh well first of
all what i'll do is i'm gonna order i'm
gonna i'm gonna say you're
quarterbacking the situation oh yeah i'm
ordering for everybody and we do that i
do that all the time we call it we call
crewskis where one person will order all
the meals i will order if say if it's
all of us i will order uh one two three
i'll order four steaks
uh they'll all be medium rare and
they'll all be sliced for us yeah we'll
get a filet we'll get a porterhouse
we'll get a rib eye we'll get we'll
we'll load it up right some dry age this
guy could probably order like no one
else you'd give tim dillon a run for
that one and then we're gonna get what i
don't know what peter lucas has on the
menu but i would love to get some pastas
i want to get a lot of like i love to go
to steakhouses and get a side pasta of
like uh shrimp scampi and because it
just it's such a different flavor we're
getting lobsters
and we're going to each get our own
lobster whoa and and then we're going to
do a seafood tower to start nice and
we're getting lots of like we're doing
all all the starches they have we'll do
all their starches and we'll have a
couple
i'm going to say i want some i want some
roasted garlic with it and then we'll do
a couple greens but not many and then
definitely bread yeah nice
we're gonna start with a martini a dirty
martini and then we're gonna speak in a
big man's language right now i'm a
manhattan man but he likes a dirty marty
we're all going with dirty martini to
start while we while we pick our wine
nice and then we go a bottle of wine
[Laughter]
which is tough luck for you buddy
yeah there's gonna be a bunch of people
coming out of the woodwork for that cash
and then when he gets done he goes do
you guys want dessert i said uh bring
out your four favorite desserts nice and
i don't even wanna i don't even want to
know what they are for the table
everybody's sharing everything
like just grabs man all right and and
i've already given my credit card you
don't wanna do that when do you do that
right right when i'm trying to learn
right when i walk in right
before i seated i give him my credit
card and i said don't i did that with
rafi may one time that was a mistake he
got paid [ __ ] no like [ __ ]
sushi it was just me and him it was 1200
it was [ __ ] he ate a dolphin
we're a big state we're we're we do
gallaghers in midtown not too far that's
our spot it's old school they like we
like what they do it's you know
everything it's like real old school
it's all mahogany they got a lump crab
cocktail that'll blow your hair back
really
ice cold chunks of just sweet delicious
crab meat fantastic we went a little bit
of remy lot a little bit of cocktails we
went to this place called red ash in
austin
red ash good
might be the best meal i've ever had in
my life it was it was it was everyone
from the tour me dave williamson steve
fury my cousin andrew my cameraman john
manz and peter
and we
got [ __ ] wasted and we ate like crazy
and then the next night i went to
uh a sushi restaurant with segura that i
did i'd been to before but i was so
drunk i don't remember it and i remember
it's fine that way they bring out two
pieces at a time two pieces two pieces
two pieces chef's menu and i was like
the last time i was there i was like a
sushi boat please and they were like we
don't do sushi boats
i'll do the shrimp tempura
[Laughter]
extra
god
ketchup
um
i'm assuming that credit card's made out
of some kind of medal
uh you know so funny i don't even have
any credit cards on me anymore really
yeah he has them what man that's the
level you're rolling at birdie boy are
you kidding me i don't have any i don't
i don't even roll with credit i hear
about that in drake songs no i i well
it's i'm you're the most successful
person i've ever met in my life i know
i'm just irresponsible i'm irresponsible
and i lose them or i or i just i [ __ ]
put them in a pocket if i use them i'll
put them in a pocket and then i'll find
them like a month later i did the same
thing with money i'll get a lot of money
and then put it in a pocket and not
realize i have it and then go out i
yeah i have a wallet on you do you have
your wallet i don't have it i have a
wallet right now
but like i haven't i lost it for i lost
it for a week i found it right before we
left last night i'd put it in a box whoa
you're handling the cat that's [ __ ]
the coolest thing i went to vegas i went
to vegas not not to flex but i went to
vegas to buy rolex flex
we want you to find successful people
coming on the show it's a big flex i
went to vegas and i and i and i i've
wanted a rolex oh i have a rolex but i
wanted to i want to buy one for this
tour to kind of remember the tour
remember this watch and i went to a
bunch of rolex places no one has any
stock and we went to this one in vegas
and i was like and segura texted me he's
like man you're busting your ass you're
one of the hardest working dudes i know
you you
he's like you fly to austin once a month
to [ __ ] do two bears you're touring
non-stop you have a movie coming out you
are burning the candle at both ends
treat yourself get the [ __ ] rolex
hell yes so i went to get the rolex and
i had to have him pay for it
it was though
he's tapping himself i was the weirdest
[ __ ] thing the lady's like he's gonna
pay for it i was like it's it's my card
but yeah he's like i pay the bill but
it's hit and so
i bought a rolex and he paid for it is
the card in his name or is that your
name it's in your name right it's a
company card with a company card with
his name yeah yeah
yeah so
hell i'm intrigued by you
yeah
holy [ __ ]
it's a nice watch i really like it good
for you man yeah thank you i really like
it i have another one my dad gave me one
when i was a kid my dad's giving me two
and and i loved the one my dad gave me
he gave it to me for my 40th birthday
but there's something different about
this one it's not as nice as the other
one but it's it's because i bought it on
tour and i've been looking at watches
and that i was like i really enjoy this
one i haven't taken it off yet he gave
me this one it's a citizen that's a good
looking one i was looking at your
watching that was our birthday present
or christmas present those both stink
i'm a movement man guys that's garbage
mvmt.com garbage these watches
stink oh my god
ah movement shout out to [ __ ]
movement
god damn it there's only one more thing
i'd like to know if i could if we have
do we have a second of course it's real
quick
you go to a wedding
close friend maybe a relative maybe a
niece or a nephew
how much kid is he putting in the
envelope
i gotta run out to the car real quick so
i'm a big time razzle dazzle guy oh he's
a little bit of a show know it that's
why i asked big guy i like it lay it on
me i like the shine i like the sparkle
of things if you want to write it down
like a rich guy and slide it across he's
real big on writing numbers down in
slides so that's what rich people do i
have a hard i have a hard time like
because i'm this i want to say this the
right way so it doesn't he says i give a
blender i'm going to shoot myself no so
uh
so i like big presents like we had a kid
like i'll tell you this
this is gonna sound crazy and if you
don't understand the backstory you're
not gonna get it i'm spending a hundred
thousand dollars on tom's birthday this
year i yes yeah yeah yeah okay so like
fantastic so like and also a tax
write-off
so yeah so smart business so i spent
money to make money you know what i mean
so if you're talking about probably i'm
the president of the party on the
president i'm buying them a race car
they started one up in each other yeah
we started one up at each other so he
bought me a three thousand dollar bike
and he and tom is the one that
introduced me
to how great presents were
how great we just did that this year
because we just started making money so
we bought each other christmas presents
and it's and it's really fun i bought
him that bass guitar
two thousand dollars did you really yeah
it was 600 he's lying dude 700.
and i got him a nintendo switch the good
one they both hate them uh so tom bob
you don't play the bass do you mind
yeah i do
tom tom bought me an electric bike for
three thousand dollars and i was blown
away by how much i loved it and how i
didn't expect it and how he kind of knew
what i wanted
and so then not a bass guitar i see what
i'm saying i said i'll buy you a better
grip gift next year and i'll spend more
money let's do that let's promise to
spend more money on each other as we go
and my gift last year was seventy
thousand dollars and now this year i had
to spend a hundred thousand dollars easy
and so the next does he know that you're
giving him this oh yeah oh yeah i had to
get his sizes for his uh flame retardant
suit like
like an actual race car i bought him a
race car we're starting a two-bedroom
car we're buying we're starting two
bears racing and it's tom's our driver
rogan will drive it don't you come to me
with these ideas and uh
are you getting in a nascar no we're
doing uh endurance racing in the in like
the i think it's the m6 series like
that kind of [ __ ] yeah like the long
ones so we'll go in it's like a 24 hour
race [ __ ] it's i bought him a 56
thousand dollar race car it's beautiful
it's an is we're getting it wrapped
right now it's uh i'm over here talking
about crab meat at some mistake
and then and then i bought him a trailer
i bought him a trailer for the car i
bought three race outfits i got a smoker
that's attached to our trailer and i got
him four new tires just in case and so
you were starting two bears racing and
the best part is we're selling ad sales
space on the car
and uh and i i'm dude it's like
i love having dumb ideas so when you
talk about like there was a kid who's
turned uh who turned
uh 13 and i and i bought him a jet ski
yeah and my wife's like what the [ __ ]
you doing i go because his dad's got to
[ __ ] keep in his garage yeah and so
and so
i don't have no problem if i'm going to
a wedding being the guy like i've been
getting drunk getting on gofundmes
lately and just i've done that dropping
money on people's gofundmes just being
and then because then you get the email
and you get to keep up with them like
there's this kid that was in an accident
from philly
i donated a bunch of money to his
gofundme and then i shared it people
hate when you share a gofundme they're
like you're rich why don't you just pay
for everything and i was like go [ __ ]
yourself i gave ten thousand dollars
okay
so i give ten thousand dollars to one
guy a guy i know who had cancer i gave
him ten thousand dollars and so i'll get
drunk and go on gofundme especially at
like a hundred bucks 500 bucks a pop
i'll take a look and see where the top
donation is yeah yeah and i always put
my name i always put my name yes what
the [ __ ] out of me anonymous can suck my
ball sack who the [ __ ] donates anonymous
money to go fund me yeah you know what i
do [ __ ] i also put burke right here but
i put five bucks
you know what i do when i go to gelson's
and they have hey do you want to donate
a dollar i go yeah sure i'll donate one
dollar and then i'll write brad pitt and
people would go brad pitt
cheapskate i made 20 million last year
yeah so if i'm going to a wedding and
you're talking about uh a a nephew a
buddy's friend i will give buddies i'll
probably give
i'll probably give 15 grand and try to
cover their their honeymoon like some of
their what i'm sorry these headphones
are [ __ ] up sound like you said 15
grand probably 15 grand if like you're
talking about like a family member yeah
like yeah yeah oh i mean i would spend
more
is that what you're asking
we're rants oh if if if you think the
next highest answer we've asked was a
thousand it was like fake oh no no no no
no no i would definitely i'm way over i
roll into chinese new year's with
2022 dollars of fresh ones and give it
away like give it away i mean i through
what's chinese new year's i said that
like i celebrate it oh chinese new
year's is the [ __ ] greatest holiday
of the [ __ ] year we just celebrated
that's where i met oliver stone at
chinese new year's
we get we get a dragon to come to the
house and then scare all the bad demons
out of the house and then we and then
it's good luck to gamble so what i'll do
is i'll get
and twenty-two the whatever year it is
whatever fresh ones it's gotta be crisp
ones and then i i just give it to kids
and i'll make the kids gamble for it i
did noses on the table so the kids kept
their noses on the table and i had 400
bucks in the center and i was like
whoever keeps her nose on the table gets
it and these are waiting for like an
hour and a half and then i and then i
take i'll take a hundred dollars throw
it in the pool and like a bag with a
rock in it and those kids will dive in
and i give away two thousand dollars and
it's fun as [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy
parties dude if you're talking
so if you're talking about like if
you're talking about like a family
member's wedding i would i was i was
given i had i was broke when i got
married and and we went to a really nice
honeymoon and we couldn't afford it and
someone covered the bill and that
that the world that changed it changed
it
it
it was told to me it was it put my
wedding on a better my marriage on a
better footing that you weren't going
out you weren't starting your wedding
the whole in the whole year you were
having fighting the greatest time you
could have and i got it i want you to
have that as a gift for your marriage
and without a [ __ ] doubt if it's a
family member i'd be like i'll take care
of it tell me what your nut is for your
uh honeymoon and then i find it out and
i just cover it and that that and i'm in
the place where i can do that right now
and it doesn't ruin me yeah so that's
what i do i mean if i was younger i
probably couldn't have done that but now
i can
mr [ __ ] christian dad you're [ __ ]
something else bro no that's why i said
hit us up if i broke your computer i'll
buy you a new one at all it's a little
wonky i just want to say
also i'm getting married next week
and the computer is 45 grand by the way
ladies and gentlemen mr burke chrysler
god damn it
holy gang we [ __ ] love you bart
anything you want to tell the folks
uh thank you for having me on i enjoy i
enjoy this podcast and it was a stretch
i was i was nervous that you guys like i
said you're gonna go we don't have time
for you dude it sounds so corny but
whatever i'm sharing it we made this
show with guys like you in mind yeah and
the fact that in two years
we started the show as [ __ ] literal
nobodies and to have you sitting at this
table meaning the world means the
[ __ ] world to us
it means so much to us that means to be
honest with that means the world that
guys like you even know who i am that
like you're crazy dude yeah i feel like
i feel like i feel like i'm not even in
the game anymore like i'm just like i
just you're one of the most successful
comedians
yeah we were talking today what are you
talking about i swear to god me t-bone
and foley had this conversation outside
maybe maybe four days ago smoking a cig
we're like all right who else can you
know let's look up what like who can we
get and we're like burp would obviously
be a great and i go
hopefully in a year we'll get them and
then two days later you texted me and my
head almost exploded well let me tell
you tom sagar's got a big tour to
promote tommy then when he comes to new
york i heard he gives 20 grand at
[ __ ]
what's he gonna break when he's in here
when tom's the girl when tom's a girl
tom's girl he's a gift yeah he is a gift
guy he is a you know what he started
doing he started bringing dudes he grew
up with on the road he'd be like let me
fly you out i'll fly you out first class
i'll put you up in a hotel i'll bring
you out to the show we'll take you to
dinner we'll do something fun that next
day and then i'll fly you home yeah it's
like a vacation for you yeah he's like
and people were like why are you doing
this and he's like because i like to
look on your face when you enjoy it
damn tom is a gift [ __ ]
man
you guys are [ __ ] next level cool bro
next level
thank you
gang we love you
we'll see you next week
bye ticket to a live show peace